Ali, I'm so excited that you're here.
You're so darn funny and amazing.
Would you like to hit some headlines with us?
Let's hit them, baby.
All right, Ross, kick it off.
All right, Ali, we are going to kick it off
with the latest on Jeopardy!.
USA Today reports the show's announced a lineup
of celeb guest hosts who are going to just do it
for a little bit, just for funsies.
They include Anderson Cooper, Savannah Guthrie
and our friend Dr. Oz.
I know.
And I remember, Ali, and I wanted to ask you specifically.
Howard Stern was talking to your husband,
George Stephanopoulos, and he actually said
that George would make a good host for Jeopardy!.
So, can you break any news here?
Has George been offered a gig?
All I can tell you is that George is not that smart.
(laughing)
So if he did host Jeopardy!, he'd need an ear piece
and I'd be having to feed him, which gets complicated.
I think George is extremely busy with GMA
and his Sunday show.
And of course all my sexual needs.
So I don't think he'd be able to fit
anything else in his schedule.
I mean, maybe Grey's Anatomy once in a while,
but he's a busy guy.
I think you could do it too though, Ali,
you'd be great.
Oh, I would love that.
I've seen you do, I mean, I just love watching you.
I am all ear and all eyes.
How fun would that be?
Oh my gosh.
Maybe we should start doing segments
on The Drew Show where we do our own Jeopardy!.
Why do we have to wait for ABC to come to us?
I love answering trivia questions
and I love you and we love games, so, okay.
It's a no brainer.
All right, we'll offline as soon as this segment is over.
I, by the way, I love how your husband
just gets you and loves your humor and celebrates you.
It's such a good--
We couldn't be married if that was not the dynamic,
because people were so, and they still are,
so curious about us.
And I always say, "you don't want two of me."
If I'd married Carrot Top, it would be a nightmare.
And you know, if George married some astro scientist
with no personality,
it'd be a little bland at a dinner party.
So I think it's, I think it's a good mix, you know?
And now we have two daughters that have
kind of a little bit of both.
I always say they have his brain and my legs,
and if it were the other way around, they'd be screwed.
(laughing)
Maybe that's what you need, Drew,
is like the counterbalance to you.
You know what I mean?
I know like Joe Manganiello was like,
"You need someone who can one up you."
I was like, "I think the Earth might implode."
(laughing)
Maybe someone to like mellow you out.
Not that you're you, but you know what I mean?
Like the opposite of--
Valium in the form of a man. Perfect.
(laughing)
That would be an emotional support dog.
Go ahead.
I have one of those, Douglas.
I have a trivia question.
How often should you replace your hairbrush?
I know that I'm gonna say the wrong thing,
because I think I still have my hairbrush
from freshman year of college.
(laughing)
Real Simple asked an expert and they say
that we should be replacing our brushes
every six months to a year.
And, you should be deep cleaning the barnacles
off that bad boy once a month.
Barnacles? Barnacles?
I know, sloughing, like a whale.
I've seen my girlfriends getting ready before we go out.
And I always say like,
"I would never judge you, but you're disgusting."
Because some of them look like a true rat's nest.
Ali, what's the state of your brush?
Well, I think the state of my brush is it's a chia pet,
kind of, I haven't found any barnacles.
I see live animals, but it's hard to tell
'cause my daughters take my brush too.
So it's a little bit of everything.
Ali, quickly tell us about your podcast,
Go Ask Ali, and what we can expect this season.
This past season was all about
how to grow a teenager in a pandemic.
This season is all about how to grow a relationship
in a pandemic, in a crazy world.
And I mean, growing a relationship with a sibling,
with a spouse, with a lover, with an aging parent,
with the UPS guy, and I've actually found
that I'm doing an episode about growing a relationship
with yourself, because during the pandemic,
every night with my two daughters, I would say,
"Let's have an ice cream bar."
And I went to the doctor and my cholesterol
was like 310, which is, I shouldn't be alive.
And I realized I'm just not taking care of myself at all
because I'm Zooming, and so you can't get the whole picture.
And I just haven't been healthy at all.
So I stopped the ice cream for a while
and I started walking with my emotional support dog, Cooper,
who's my other husband, and sort of started to get healthy,
but I realized so many, don't you guys find
that so many relationships during this time
have been fractured or you're not seeing your girlfriends
as much and maybe you don't need all these people
in your life, maybe you just need a core group?
So I've had everybody, Glennon Doyle, everybody,
my bestie Mariska Hargitay,
like so many people weighing in
on how we grow these healthy relationships right now.
I love that you're talking about the relationship
with yourself, too.
And reevaluating.
I think this pandemic has made us reevaluate everything.
Listen, everyone is going to be in relationships
throughout their life.
I love that you're covering all different types of them
because there are all different types out there,
but we are always navigating relationships.
And everything you just said was so astute.
I'm just gonna hang on your every word.
Ali Wentworth, her podcast, Go Ask Ali,
is out now with new episodes coming in March
and I can't thank you enough.
And let's sidebar
about more, more, more.
I love you both so much.
(upbeat music)